we need to burn some sage slow-like
Christian today we're trying stinky
cheeses are you a big cheese person I
mean coming from pasty you have to be
right I'm a huge cheese person instead
of dinner is to eat like a block of Brie
nothing like trying some stinky cheese
like first thing in the morning wake you
right up okay I can smell that ones
that's more than stinky this is really
nasty it's like sour this is the cheese
that they've started at the beginning of
time aging and now it's finally
eradicate it smells like something died
in a sewer should we do this cheering
have them oh I'm only doing half I'm
just gonna see what happens yeah I mean
it's strong there's not bad hmm let it
grow hmm it's growing yeah it tastes
like better basil and then you're like
oh there comes the data animal it tastes
like it smells I really like the
creaminess of it like a love creamy
cheese so when I first took a bite that
was enjoyable
you can probably warm this up and make
it like soft which would be good soft
and stinky it sounds like my ex yeah I
don't think I'd buy it for a party
because it's not a smell I want in my
house but if there was like a fancy
restaurant offering another taste it
might take another taste I wouldn't go
out of my way to eat this I want to pay
for this talk to me after five glasses
of wine and maybe I'll have a different
answer but as it stands right now it's a
note for me nope oh oh that's a
different bad smell it's wrong
there's like a huge patch of mold on top
and we're just supposed to eat it it's
not mold this is okay oh god she like
she hold it
God you look at zombie cheese I'm sorry
I feel like no I'm like a cowardly
cheese lover where's my craft where's my
craft single I need it I guess I'm
guessing this is a British cheese
British people are not known for their
cuisine or their orthodonture a what's
yours
the blue cheese and they go very frog
easy I'm very relieved yeah with that
I'm team this emptiness the scent does
not translate to the tape hmm it's
actually a very mild flavor yeah I
wouldn't bring it into my home nope
it smells way too bad but this is good I
like it turn out of town would eat again
this one is not cute oh that's a tome a
toe smell this one the other two I was
like ready to dive in it through the
his'n like this one I'm nervous to eat
I'm not a dramatic person that is so bad
just like eat the air around it it looks
like it's going through an identity
crisis yeah what is that you're going
through like all the stages that's great
over this cheese can we just eat this
cuz I need to get this out of my face do
you want a cracker I don't even know
what part I'm supposed to go the part
that looks like she's stable good luck
don't always it tastes just like it
smells
[Music]
don't breathe in it literally translates
a little monster well no wonder that was
bad its I'm still getting with severe
that is a capital drinking water your
hospital no I do not recommend this go
man I don't get this cheese cheese I'm
like oh not so bad smells like your
Grandpa's feet love yeah this is like
some fancy beauty oh my god yeah it
smells really sour I'm so over this Bon
Appetit Bon Appetit
cheers Cheers they don't pass out no one
gum oh okay I didn't hate that well it
wasn't the worst
I honestly my nostrils are described
right now premium has a little bite
doesn't smell good the taste jump down
you want the unsticky a-- stinkiest
cheese so with this one okay so this is
strong but not nasty smell oh yeah very
gorgonzola I'm here for this yeah I also
think this is pretty that swirls in it
or nice yes it smells but the smell is
like it's a little more kind it's a
kinda stink this looks like you've got
more than one digit in your bank account
type cheese you know what I mean
I can't wait cuz I'm a single digit
alright now I'm getting a mold free
piece just cuz I've had a lot of mold
today I'm doing
a generous portion I'm just gonna put
that on that yeah mines glistening so
now I'm a little unsure thank you let it
get sweating more than I am that's
really gross so it's you well and you
know because it was an experience I
think I hate blue cheese way less I
think I've built my tolerance ooh I love
that sounds good mmm like garnish cheese
I feel like I've had it on a salad
mm-hmm perfect for wine night I think -
I like her I think she's you I've been
she's a girl like you least expect to be
like the banker but she is yeah that one
that one was a good one to end on
favorite of the day favorite of the day
mmm mold well snow somewhat similar yeah
but then the taste was all over the
place
okay I'm glad we've tasted these cheeses
I'm glad to be able to exploit that we
tried them ok I'm not because I can't
really judge a cheese based on its smell
no that's a real life lesson I think we
learned today and now we know what we
don't like okay it's always valuable
yeah what you're not fond of I mean we
found one cheese that we do really like
that's true
[Music]